they've been closing a ton of them have
they yeah fire was the last time you
hate Burger King you hate Burger really
it's the worst that's what I mean why do
you have such a strong opinion on it
like what do you hate about it to me
he's so concerned he's just freaking
mole
[Music]
we have presenting oh my God
cheeseburger that's crazy is there meat
or is it just all cheese no it's all
cheeses 20 slabs of cheese that actually
looks really good does it though maybe
because I'm on a diet oh yeah so this
Burger King in Thailand they made what
they call the real cheeseburger I
thought Asians were lactose and thong
they're trying to make them [__]
themselves they probably got fake cheese
yeah oh fake cheese because you know all
the uh milk products in Asia I could
handle but I think they have a different
formula oh to deal with the lactoseness
of the Asians I think the cows are just
a monkey Dairy they're just yeah they're
just Asian cows
there's like a [__] gorilla just
squeezing out titty milk inside yeah the
cows were lactose as well so that's why
that milk works for Asians out there
yeah that's true when I drink all the
milk from those like Japanese or
Taiwanese milk farms I don't fart later
really yeah that milk's good
I just made it when I was in Thailand I
had a I had a pork burger there like it
was like a regular hamburger oh was it
good I don't remember I was like 13.
there's so many things in other
countries that I think are so bombed
that I wish we had here in America like
what specifically at like the uh Chinese
McDonald's they have uh two MC spicy
chicken wings yeah oh I heard about them
they're so bomb they're spicy and
they're just bombed they're in the
burger no no just like chicken on the
side two chicken wings you just order
but they're spicy should we put the bone
in yeah like wings I wish we had the
Malaysian spicy chicken nuggets oh yeah
or at least the sauces like the curry
sauce for chicken nuggets oh my God when
you went to the McDonald's HQ do they
have all the international yeah wow so
the we I went to the McDonald's I did it
was so cool so it's a whole building
and it says McDonald University
and then um on the bottom floor there's
a there's a McDonald's there that has a
rotating menu of different things that
they offer internationally because at
the HQ they they keep testing and
whatever and where is it uh Chicago yeah
I think we saw at the time a Japanese
parfait and then there was some French
uh pastry and whatever so they have the
regular menu and then they have the
international rotating menu
and inside the building there's like a
mock McDonald's so you could go inside
and like film [__] or whatever and it's
a working kitchen working everything if
you work there it's like you just get
anything like they just they just make
McDonald's whatever you want but this is
in the building they need to tell kids
this because that would have been my job
dude if I was like in fifth grade and
told me you could be at McDonald's
employee for the rest of your life at a
high level I'm like working at the
McDonald's
yeah and then the main uh I don't know
if he's still the main chef but I think
Ronald his name was chef Mike or
whatever
he's really cool he's a Barbecue Pit
Master that's his main thing it's not a
microwave master
and I was like yes I was like micro wave
that's his name
I was like why do you guys why do you
need a chef there's like two main chefs
at any given time and I'm like why you
guys need an actual Chef yeah because
your formula is already done and he goes
oh it's like we're constantly uh doing
different like initiatives like they'll
come out with different things right
like there might be like the bacon bits
or like whatever yeah and then I was
like that's [__] interesting and then
they keep uh
making sure the quality control and
stuff oh wow do you think this is good
marketing because I know Burger King's
been like hurting right they've been
closing a ton of them have they yeah
I hate Burger King you hate bird really
it's the worst that's what I mean why do
you have such a strong opinion on it
like what do you hate about it to me
he's so concerned he's just freaking
mole I go McDonald's [__] childhood
right yeah yeah that's like straight
[__] crack to your childhood dreams
like Nostalgia of course teleport there
then probably like Carl's Jr Jack In The
Box and Carl's is good Wendy's Wendy
I'll take that yeah I'm with you I've
never even ate Sonics but I bet Sonics
where's Jack in the Box in all of them
Jack in the Box it's all up in there
right the only times I ever get Burger
King is when I'm at the airport which is
a good station and it sucks ass there
what do you get it's about Fair because
airport fast food is never as good but
the Popeyes is good sometimes at the air
sometimes and McDonald's breakfast at
the airport is always it's always good
so Burger King has also has the wackest
fries because it's too big to be
McDonald's
I mean it's too it's uh it's not small
enough to be McDonald's but it's also
not big enough to be a potato wedge so
it's right in the middle where it's the
worst size ever I was always down for
their uh their French toast sticks I do
like that okay Burger King does things
very well the things they do very well
are their stick shaped Foods they're
[__] chicken fries I think they're
they're french fries are pretty good
David and Hannah like they're good
but you know what I used to get
McDonald's the spicy chicken that's
shaped like a [__] football that's
good so you know how like when fast food
things are hurting they always come out
with a ridiculous thing to get to get
attention you think that's what this is
I absolutely think that's what it is you
know they came out with uh pork spare
ribs one time and that was Bob Burger
King yeah Burger King yes remember that
yes it was good they just need to do a
collab like the like a Travis Scott they
did the McDonald's burger they just
didn't collab with someone McDonald's
collabs are wild though yeah just make
the Grimace Shake oh the Grimace Shake
is making its rounds dude that's that's
everywhere I don't know what it is I
want to try it but everyone is like
making videos about it where they do
this thing where they'll drink it and
then they'll end up like dead on the
floor
that's good marketing it's good like oh
for real and part of me questions like
did McDonald's like manufacture this do
they go hey to a bunch of these
different Tick Tock creators hey can you
guys make a fun cool thing with our
grandma Shake I'm curious because it's
everywhere yeah it's everywhere but I I
think no amount of marketing is gonna
make their burgers at Burger King taste
better
I think it's just to remind you they
exist it's not good yeah yeah but
they're Burgers I mean this is their
marketing they took out the meat yeah
it's kind of funny I'd rather have
Arby's than [__] Burgers Arby's is
bomb though you know what Arby's gets a
lot of it they hate that it gets is
undeserved I feel like Arby's yeah
[Laughter]
you know [__] like Jimmy John's I'm like
how do you stay in business oh I think I
think they have a new I think they have
an audience I've never been in the mood
for us like submarines yeah I'd rather
do a Jimmy John's than uh Subway I think
that's like a blue collar thing yeah
Philly cheesesteak that's different yeah
that's not a subject but Jersey Mike's
got some good Subs bro but I don't even
give a [__] about Subs but when I go to
Jersey son when I go to Jersey Mike's
it's mostly like white dudes that are
like
Their audience is very specific it's
like it's like blue collared like men
like why the [__] do you want to eat a
[__] cold thing
I don't get that either dude I don't
understand that I like cold I like cold
sandwiches yeah bro Italian sandwiches
are cold but then would you do you
choose it over [__] salami dude
cotton ready see I'd rather go if I if
there's Italian deli and they toast the
bread and it's cold cuts they have olive
oil I might rather go that yeah I don't
want [__] cold bread cold meat cold
everything oh hell yeah dude on a hot
ass day [__] a tuna sandwich with
Alfalfa and [__] they [__] make it
like this big talk to me man
or Jersey Mike's oh no I mean like at a
deli yeah yeah see yeah bro I want to
get a tuna melt the other day yeah or
like a like an Italian sub when they
throw like salami and balani and the
salami Kalani
to me that's like a bomb meat but like
Bobby's more better I like those [__]
Jewish ones too like those Rubens
Cubans
Cuban sandwiches Cuban sandwiches
give me a [__] pickle and some
pastrami see you can't beat that yeah
hey the other day I was I was training
with David before he went to get uh
dinner with you and he was late as [__]
nah he wasn't late David goes dude
Bart's at this stage it was dieting
because when he's dieting all he wants
to do is just talk about food so he'll
just send me pictures and food and I
could tell when we're talking about this
he's like oh this and this your your
food motivator right now aren't you yeah
it becomes your main interest before I
was like when I'm like in a halfway diet
or it's not that extreme I don't really
like looking at like food porn type
stuff because I'm like oh that's just
gonna tantalize me but then now it's at
the point where my explore page is all
food because it at least satisfies a
little bit of something like I'll see
like oh they make Turtles like that
that's pretty cool
dude Vegas got some bomb ass
dude the Hawaiian spot they have over
there Loco Moco with fried rice with two
spam and egg on top
I found a place that makes katsuma uh
musubis too
full list of Vegas food that I need to
try gotta go to Uncle Frank's man you
know what's interesting it is really
when you think about it it's difficult
for fast food places to make new items
without appropriating somebody oh now
pretty hard if you think about it
because now all these fools are trying
to add Boba to their [__] exactly like
they gotta like tread carefully right
yeah
but as long as it's [__] bombed I
can't have a katsu Whopper out of
nowhere you know you gotta like nah you
gotta say it's for stop Asian haters it
sounds good well you don't call it katsu
you just call it like shake and bake
chicken is that worse imagine but
remember they're doing the dumb shits
like a couple years ago with a [__]
rapping fud into a burrito no
Japan
one Japan everybody got their own
version though every country got their
own version of battered chicken yeah
right but it's how they do it they cut
inside Japanese versions of anything
else is the best it's top tiers
they can't innovate but they can steal
like a [__] Japanese can't
innovate like they do innovate yo
they're almost rice though like Japanese
no one else does it that way they just
they're good at perfecting and then they
just make it their own to the point
where you think that they made it up
like Robin like that's just Chinese oh
and now but that's technically a wok so
that's technically Chinese too yeah all
right everything's technically tiny yeah
bro they've been around for a long time
they're not the inventors no they just
steal the [__] out of it that's Korea
they just perfect but what about
Nintendo is that Japanese it is I mean
they made it right but yeah what's Atari
what's atario is it white or what are
they Chinese American they're like Tech
guys here and dead dude they're dead in
the water died they all died they didn't
even have grapes it's funny because
Atari sounds Japanese too it does yeah
if you say it like
it's really Atari
[Music]